no one's copy to say 15 minutes to
collect their personals can we pick up
the past like each other a for daytime
soap star and the matriarch of the rose
family Moira quickly became a fan
favorite with her comedic timing I need
you to work the motel this Friday you
know what we're all pitching in these
days dear like communists or non-union
actors outrageous style heading to the
cafe it's always nice to dress for
dinner and unforgettable over-the-top
wigs each wig represents a different
layer of her pert I'm not even a trait
like it was a full presence person but
not only in a weird way with Katherine
transforming into the eccentric
character the Toronto native left her
mark sweeping the Canadian Screen Awards
for best comedy actress four years in a
row you can't be serious Katherine's
unique approach to her character made
her a standout on the small screen I was
served by an intimidating woman at the
front desk with an unrecognizable accent
and scary-looking attire and what might
this have to do with me Laura that
unrecognizable accent and portable
delivery contributed to the addition of
a new word in the unofficial shits Creek
dictionary
maire ism which is defined as a casual
pre tension or an unfiltered opinion on
regular people regular people regular
people or how Rose video became such a
nice girl careful regular people I mean
they made us who we were what am I
trying to say and ever the comedic
actress Catherine is responsible for
some of the most iconic scenes of the
series including this one come taste the
difference good fruit can make in your
wine you'll remember the experience and
you'll remember the name her birth wing
her bird her grave
irv herb linger bing live hunger a scene
so loved by fans that they took to
youtube in tribute sharing parodies
online and at least attempting to
capture some of the true magic that is
motor rose and the love for shits Creek
is contagious with Hollywood taking
notice including Oscar winner Jennifer
Lawrence much to the surprise of creator
Dan levy Jennifer Lawrence I love you I
love that Chelsea that's amazing
yeah when one of us shines all of us
shine that is the meaning of an song